this week we're talking about protecting
sensitive data choosing the right cloud
architecture and cube con 2019 I'm
Stephanie and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the Lois Lane C
News cloud data loss prevention is a
powerful service that brought
state-of-the-art data protection to a
variety of workloads and storage formats
and now it's even better with an
easy-to-use UI
making those capabilities available to
your security compliance and legal teams
learn more about scanning your data
setting up regular monitoring and
identifying trends no terminal required
speaking of sensitive data it's time to
revisit best practices for password
management October is famous for being
national cybersecurity Awareness Month
while it can be fun to dress up as
someone else for Halloween it's a lot
less fun when someone dresses up like
your bank account so in honor of the
holiday Google released two white papers
discussing modern password security for
users and for system designers happy
holiday reading one size fits most is
not a policy we believe works for cloud
solutions that's why Google cloud offers
a variety of products and many
configurations if you find yourself
caught between compute engine and
kubernetes engine you're not alone we
created two architecture training paths
so that you can learn more about virtual
machines containers and make the best
choice for you and speaking of
kubernetes cube con and cloud native con
2019 is happening November 18th to the
21st in San Diego California if you want
to learn more about cloud solutions of
all sorts you should come register
online today or on-site at the
conference if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you